in this episode of cloud performance
atlas I helped some foodies bring home
the bacon by profiling their startup
time can their architecture stand the
heat stay tuned to find out I gave a
talk in New York last week where I met
the people behind foodie pics a social
network that only allows you to share
pictures of food no text no audio no
emoji just a picture of food and the geo
locate a guerre it was taken at turns
out their team had read my previous
articles on app engine startup
performance and wanted to reach out and
see if I could help them with a similar
issue while talking to their team over a
round of free pizza I got a clearer
sense of their architecture as a user
uploaded a picture of food it was sent
to a compute engine instance where it
ran some logic and processing on the
picture to make sure it's really an
image of food now I didn't really figure
anything was wrong until they showed me
a graph which looks something like this
they were seeing about 300 second cold
boot time for their applications while
the response latency for a request was
in the 300 millisecond range now to be
fair by this point I hadn't really dug
in to compute engine cold boot
performance that much so I was happy to
use this as an excuse to investigate
further now you may see a common trend
in my performance debugging pattern at
this point when trying to track down
performance issues like this I first
like to remove my code and establish a
baseline to know how badly my code is
impacting things as such the first steps
in figuring out the problem was to run a
quick test to see if number one given a
static configuration how long compute
engine instance takes to boot up and
number two given changes in that
configuration how does that impact the
previous number so let's start with a
simple test just 15 iterations of
starting an instant and timing how long
until we can SSH into it
on average a two CPU eight gig VM took
about 60 seconds to boot up which I
think does a nice job of establishing
our baseline now I would assume that
improving resources should see an
improvement in cold boot time since
there's more cycles available to help
the image get up and running so I
doubled the core and memory count and
saw an average of about 63 seconds a
little worse but still within margin of
error this made me wonder if increasing
the CPU and RAM caused boot
to degrade linearly to test that I
increased both by 8x and so the average
time was about 62 seconds which doesn't
exactly conform to my thought that VM
start-up time would be linear with
resource requested more so that these
timing fluctuations were had something
to do with the small size of my sample
set
that being said GCE did recently update
the max number of CPUs you can request
in a VM to 64 and when testing we did
see that these had consistently higher
cold boot time than their less than 32
core counterparts so just to make sure
we wrap this all together let's do 200
configurations of random CPU and RAM
sizes and see what we get after testing
this about 20 times the average still
look to be about 62 seconds and to be
clear those valleys and spikes don't
correlate with a specific configuration
they move around pretty regularly
between iterations of the test this
whole thing let me know two important
facts number one cold boot time of
compute engine VMs are not correlated
with CPU Ram configurations directly and
number two the 302nd cold boot time that
the foodie pic VMs we're seeing is being
caused by something else so let's get
some more information about Buddha now
obviously we need to install the
operating system on the VM maybe we were
using some weird configuration of image
that I wasn't testing with so let's put
them head-to-head keep the configuration
the same but test a Linux instance
versus a Windows instance and see if
that could be the problem not
surprisingly there was some variation in
the results most of the Linux based
builds acted pretty similar but the
window builds were drastically slower
and just to get visibility I also tested
booting clusters of machines so seeing
how one VM booted versus 20 at the same
time showed some big differences with
the Windows VMs but foody pics wasn't
using Windows VM they were using Linux
VMs and only launching about one or two
at a time so the choice of an image
isn't having anything to do with their
slow cold boot performance now one nice
side effect of profiling things is that
when you typically end up learning more
about some part of the system that you
didn't have visibility to before or
rather you end up adding transparency to
a previous
black box system for me running these
tests showed off a few parts of the
system I didn't know about namely the
compute engine has a distinct latency in
various stages of VM budda process as a
request comes in to create a new
instance GCE will move through the
stages with variants latency attached to
it just to kick the tyre I enlisted the
help of fellow Cloud da Terry Ryan and I
was able to get a profile on each of
these stages which actually didn't
reveal any specific problems other than
the specific startup process you can
expect about seven seconds dedicated to
responding to a request at about 18
seconds dedicated to provisioning the VM
before any of your code starts running
now at this point it's unclear what's
causing foody pick start time to be so
slow but we have eliminated cpu ram
configurations and image selection as
culprits sadly though I only have so
much time in each one of these videos so
if you want to see what solved the
problem check out the rest of the cloud
performance Atlas content and remember
when it comes to performance every
millisecond counts